1010 no no very expensive crazy
expensive being a baby-boomer meant that
there were always for Debbie's in my
class there were no Moe's in my class I
went to Sac State I was a
photojournalism major I went to Cal
State Long Beach
I do remember having to borrow money to
buy textbooks I think my most expensive
textbook was probably $25 a very big
contrast between when we went to college
and and of course college students now
[Music]
Wow textbooks there's so much more
expensive down they are we can guess how
close we are so here's an anatomy and
physiology textbook I'm gonna win assume
science textbooks are more well because
the cover is so nice it is it has
somebody doing yoga I'm going to kiss
our daughters on a college yet but I
hopes about 200 bucks I was gonna say
like 90 bucks
woohoo I was close are you serious I
have no words but viscous fluid flow
yeah this book has got to be very cheap
because who the hell would buy a throw
that has a negative connotation was 300
and this looks like a much more popular
book it could be for medical students
though no I'm going away up I'm going
for a while these prices are crazy for
me 350
come oh wow look pretty good probably
just take the book home this book is
called film history an introduction
third edition I'm gonna get 200 there's
a lot of film students in LA probably
very expensive because you got to have
money to go to film school I would
imagine I'm gonna say 400 bucks
whoa okay I said 200 he said 400
bond portfolio investing another
exciting novel and risk management so
it's like two novels and 100 citing as a
title is 175 I'm gonna say 115 because
it seems like it's a little out of date
whoo Deborah wins again I'll be keeping
scores I am it's a competition I am
another business book retail management
thirteenth edition Wow
a strategic approach it comes from a
major publisher Pearson cover is really
boring 150 write that 100 you are that
operating room skills oh geez
I know what do you want to have these if
you're done here you do want to have
operators because it's such an important
book by Nancy okay I'm gonna say 300 150
can we want doctors okay what are their
books they want doctors to have operate
another science book molecular nature of
matter and change eighth edition
mcgraw-hill publishers remember they
were pricey I'm gonna click on the book
they do click clocks
that's a Boomer thing because of the
click clack so I'm gonna say probably
200 yeah I'm gonna say 400 due diligence
in business transactions wrote itself
okay not even a picture on the cover
come on guys 125 bucks I'm gonna say 50
so doll no no there's not even a picture
on it they only have to sell one and
they're okay for the week mail we make
up for that horrible cover with this
pretty well how beautiful interiors an
introduction I'm going to say 150 200
bucks
yes Debbie wins again calculus yeah not
my favorite subject single variable
calculus yeah me too because it is only
single variable not double I'm gonna
guess hundred bucks
oh no no no math textbooks I'm gonna put
it up for you
I'm not saying woohoo because it's good
that is so expensive like this here is
Osborne's brain imagining pathology and
Anatomy I mean an probably very complex
person yes we're learning about her
brain I think it is for medical school
so I am going to see three hundred and
fifty dollars three hundred bucks
millennial but Debbie's this is
biochemistry and it has an illustration
not a very good one but because the
other medical book was low so I'm gonna
guess seventy-five bucks Oh
I think you are a winner there comes a
nursing book mm the concept based
approach to learning okay this has got
to be economically priced I mean come on
I think anything in the medical field is
quite pricey but I'm gonna say 75 I'm
gonna be nice 150 bucks out for a nurse
Oh for nurses we need nurses
investigations in environmental geology
third edition its environmental
photographs very nice no people with
them this looks like a very important
book they all are important $175
okay I'm gonna say oh my goodness how
did you with that I think the most I
spent one semester was $250 total on
books I do feel really bad that textbook
prices are so high for students I worry
that it's going to excluded a lot of
people from college just goes across the
board with a cost of living in general
remember really struggling with books I
remember struggling with equipment and
watching film film Millennials film oh
it was in a row
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]